this is from uh san francisco gate.com
the you remember the san francisco gay
men's chorus uh they put out this song
we have to play the song again for you
just just to remind you what we're
talking about
uh but the san francisco gaming course
they put out a song last week
where they're saying that they're coming
for our children they want to convert
our children let's play the song again
and we can all remember
this uh musical masterpiece you think
we're sinful
you fight against our rights you say we
all lead lives you can't respect
but you're just frightened you think
that
we'll corrupt your kids if our agenda
goes unchecked
it's funny just this once you're correct
we'll convert your children
happens bit by bit quietly and subtly
and you will barely notice it
you can keep him from disco warn about
san francisco
make him wear pleated pants we don't
care
we'll convert your children
we'll make them tolerant and fair
okay and then it gets then we get the
entire chorus saying
we're coming for your children they
repeat that over and over again um
and they no as far as i know there was
no gun to their head forcing them to do
this
they made a decision i mean they put
that's just a decision they put a lot of
time and effort
into writing this song producing it
singing it performing it putting it out
there for the world
and the response was very negative
from a lot of people and thank god it
was negative
but now the san francisco gay men's
chorus uh they're saying
they're the victims just so you know the
fact that um
this repulsive piece of propaganda they
put out there
received a negative reaction that makes
them the victims feel sorry for them
not our children who they say they are
quote coming for
but they're the victims so from
sfgate.com says the san francisco gay
men's course says its members are being
harassed online
and receiving death threats after a
satirical video
satirical video that prominently
features the phrase will convert your
children
when viral among conservatives those
dastardly conservatives conservatives
pounce
the video which is no longer public on
the group's official accounts but can be
found elsewhere online was first posted
thursday
last week the course says it did not
start picking up steam in right-wing
spaces until the middle of this week
and then they put out a statement in
fact i have the statement here
it says this is the statement from the
gay men's court says the san francisco
gay men's course was founded in part to
fight discrimination and bigotry against
all peoples
today our chorus members are facing
death threats vile attacks
false accusations doxing and other forms
of harassment
because of our satirical video
performance message from the gay
community
we let's just stop there sati what is it
satirizing exactly you're satirizing
yourself
are you satirizing your own agenda
what is the satire
we placed the video in private mode to
quell the intolerance and hateful
responses from mostly anonymous people
upon reflection we've made it live again
for all to see
uh the obviously satirical
tongue-in-cheek humor
we want everyone to judge for themselves
we will not allow ourselves even the
face of death threats
to retreat or bow to attempts to twist
our words
meaning self-deprecation and humor
oh it's self-deprecation now they're
making fun of themselves
did that did that come through at all in
what you just listened to there you
watched the entire video
self-deprecation
um we are thankful for the efforts of
the san francisco police department and
law enforcement for their quick response
and assistance in handling these threats
the san francisco gay men's course is
dedicated to being role models teaching
and spreading the message
of love inclusion humor and celebration
through our music
oh love and inclusion
is uh that's that's it's all about love
and and inclusion when you tell parents
we're coming for your children
you know we we need to to teach your
kids like the
the best possible interpretation
the most generous interpretation for the
san francisco gay men's chorus
is that this was a song meant to mock
conservative parents
and to send the message to us that we
are not capable of raising kind
uh good people and that's why we need
the san francisco gay men's chorus to
step in and and the lgbt community
generally speaking
to teach our kids how to be kind and
generous
and tolerant and loving and accepting
that again is the
best possible interpretation
and even on the best possible
interpretation uh
people reacted exactly as anyone should
expect them to react
what do you think people are going to do
of course they're going to be angry
i don't condone death threats but like i
always say with this anytime someone
gets backlash online
for doing or saying something that's
truly objectionable they always claim oh
i got hundreds and hundreds of death
threats maybe you did
i don't actually believe it until you
produce the receipts and you show us
um this idea that there's this deluge of
of death threats maybe but i don't
believe
anyone who claims that until you until
you prove it
and even then that does nothing to get
you off the hook
yeah you shouldn't be getting death
threats but you also shouldn't have
put out the content that you put out
and as far as people reacting in general
just hatefully
yeah that's fully justified
it's a hateful message you put out there
and it gets a hateful i hate the message
the message that you want to convert my
children you're coming for my children
i'm not capable of raising them to be
loving and all of these things
and i need your assistance i hate that
message
and so my response is going to be
hateful towards the message that you
decided to put out there
[Music]
you're not the victim at all well i hope
you enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content